what the hell is wrong with you back
there Brad you lost your [ __ ] like big
time you almost killed me why don't we
talk come on no come on that's
ridiculous
what the [ __ ] is going on with this ship
because I gotta be honest it feels like
there's some like like evil like literal
evil going on down there
let's just stay calm and relatively
saying about this okay this stuff I saw
it's like there were these old soldiers
there were bodies they were dead but
then they came alive and that doesn't
sound that crazy right about now Alex
wasn't the only Alex what are you
talking about
there were things walking around with
his face on them Alex's face it was
horrifying Julia I'd never hurt you you
know that right no I know it's just this
can't all be happening maybe like one
thing could but not all of these crazy
things it's too much of a coincidence
there's got to be something going on
here
what can we absolutely be sure about
what do we know that's real
did you see the gold anything manchurian
gold isn't actually gold
it's a [ __ ] chemical and it's leaking
all over cargo hold ooh yeah I'm pretty
sure this isn't exactly what our
friendly fisherman's are expecting
neither this should go over well what
happened to everybody on this ship where
did they all go I can't shake the
feeling we're in one big floating coffin
so where'd all the corpses come from
they actually look like they've been
scared to death
we know more than we did before that's
something at least we're wasting time
whatever we do we have to do it now time
to get off the ship we're not going
anywhere without the distributor cap the
Duke needs it to run hold on this ships
gotta have a radio if we can find it and
use it that's great but do you think it
still works just need to find a way up
there
we gotta get off the stamp ship no [ __ ]
I think we were speaking clinically
totally effed
I know it sounds crazy but maybe it was
these guns that took down the plane from
our dive
great could he use these if they weren't
swiss-cheesed
find a way up sadly no but I'll keep my
eyes open
Hey a little help over here
I think this is our way up give me a
little hmm I'll pull you up
over here got away through here
[Music]
final review you know but there's gotta
be a radio on the ship there there has
to be a LAN exactly confident about our
chances of survival at this point
something's wrong here if you were
headed to San Francisco you'd be crazy
to take this route it's almost like they
didn't want anyone to know they were
coming like I didn't seek out in the
ocean
ship was blown off of course cloud cover
was bad they couldn't establish a
position
take a look
no freakin way this thing actually still
works well radio science hasn't changed
much in 70 years as long as there's
power I'll give it a whirl it's working
it's a number station
military bamboo it's absolutely no hey
hey is anyone out there hearing this
hello if you can hear us we're on a ship
an old freighter our coordinates are
approximately 12 degrees 30 minutes
south 151 degrees 20 minutes west please
get here now we need help
Ronna Freder abandoned huge and old
hello hello is anyone out there
please come in
Hey look
this has got to lead somewhere maybe we
can find a way to get the power back we
need to get that radio working I think
someone should wait here in case a
message comes through I'll go obviously
I can do this I should be the one to go
a little bro what's up I'm thinking you
might deserve a promotion
how's medium bro sale what do you when
you talk about half stepped up to the
plate put yourself right in the line of
fire you're kind of mixing metaphors
they're not if the pictures of machine
gun I'm impressed
seriously so what do you think I got I
got this not losing you to this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm coming to hey what Julie you
know you're not always gonna be there to
protect big guy I can handle this
trust me I'm still the captain of
something and the captain's telling you
that I'm going to all right you and me
flis
you still alive you guys all right down
there I'm okay you see anything I don't
know where the hell we are okay here by
the radio hey
this way
looks like we're not lower levels of the
[ __ ]
you know your dad was growing by the
hour now I really know I would have
thought we've graduated to charge by the
minute
know your invoice hey [ __ ] following
yeah all right hello lighting advice
making charge for this think I go in
here thank you very much
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] controls are [ __ ]
terrible
okay I'm going this way
I drop down yeah I hate this guy I'll
tell you I [ __ ] hate this guy [ __ ]
wuss what a [ __ ] right now
never better Mike Wayne and as he asked
oh she like a calm place wedding or
[ __ ] now that's he [ __ ]
as he shits our home Lantern
it's my desktop audio not doing Shere
Khan
yeah alright not Zack let's see here
shutting that recording [ __ ] sound
howled ah this is so [ __ ] up so [ __ ]
up okay okay it's Kelly why is it sound
like [ __ ] do it I think
okay let me add a new [ __ ] audio
input
now
this is so [ __ ] this is so [ __ ]
where's this shot
yeah here we go oh my god
sorry guys sorry sorry hey to deal with
this hello this is kind of making sense
none of that stuff happened I was
hallucinating
we knew the crew was scared of something
and that could be it yeah maybe so could
this have anything to do with the
wrecked plane from the dive I don't know
it seems like the plane came in contact
with the ship but it's just a theory
Wow okay let's keep going rates here so
like this is actually at the bottom of
my list top my list as it reads is
coming
thus here I'll see [ __ ] does God respect
I found it hey it's working
no wonder the power keeps cutting out
this thing is barely running just throw
this switch and let's go back upstairs
okay okay let's get back up there
we'll have to find a new way up
hell you have to help us do you read me
please we are in danger okay we're in a
real goddamn mess out here every needs
help now over [ __ ] work [ __ ]
Hey look at this the rebreather
I bet the fisherman brought it from the
Duke you think it still works it's gone
maybe a few minutes over your left worth
taking with us it's gonna slow us down
and not forget it's too heavy to drag
along with us
leave it [ __ ] not worth the risk
[Music]
stop them - man - aah - aah - Scalise
and gentle man hey could he could
no triple self-study
[Music]
but not anymore giving such a display
mall with my champagne who's that dr.
dey
no [ __ ]
mr. hammer there's no use hiding your
little foot what's the problem with
sharing all that cool yeah there must be
plenty of that to go around more than
enough and we're all in this together
right trying to cut me out of the deed
you can't have all the goo and then to
be left here but I am the captain
I knew stay
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay all right not changing
none of that raise your hands up not
like that
I said no changing oh listen listen to
me we have no fight with you all just
want to get out of here safely you
understand I'm sorry but if you're
breathing then you don't got much of a
choice in the matter
you don't gotta say not again
it's all good changing on me what what's
changing stay away stay back from the
mist hey there's no Mis man don't leave
it don't break the mist now you need to
slow down stop stop you feel one of us
isn't it put the gun down now why would
you say that why are you telling me what
to do
yeah you put it in the mist it's
happening I can feel it
okay look it was something in the last
room of a fog or a mist may be what I
thought
no no I mean the other breath man then
the mist is not inside of us I know
you're all fancy divers but you expect
me to buy that we've been down here for
hours
you've been holding your breath this
whole time holding your breath right now
what was it to me I got the mist inside
stop stop lying you cannot see it in the
consumer notice lying the missus inside
Hey
[Music]
walk
[Music]
the cat daddy that's there's a Bolton it
did like hey the guys not gonna [ __ ] him
down
just turn it sideways man
Oh fantastic let's just keeps getting
better and better it's a dead end we
have to go back I'm not [ __ ] drowning
today no way
this is just riveting come on guys where
are you hey hey what's happening is
everyone okay please be okay please be
okay
I got to go after him well we got to go
down there and make sure everything's
okay
Jesus did something go wrong I'll find
them make sure they're okay you stay
here with the radio come on
what have you died down there what then
I'm gonna stay as far away from trouble
as I can and they'll be back as soon as
I find the generator it'll it'll be fine
watch yourself down there I'll make the
call as soon as the radio comes back on
so you better hurry the [ __ ] back
[Music]
you tell me I just walked this whole
[ __ ] way in the game could give me a
had [ __ ] [ __ ]
Wow
I need a chicken nugget that's what I
need I need a chicken nugget I'm serious
dude I'm not always serious but I'm
[ __ ] serious this time I need a
chicken not again I cursed I'll drop
that I have no shoes
and he beat shots in there
air conditioner make sure it still has
it's like cooling systems like a jock do
you know that that's yeah someone else
perished
just chopped it [ __ ] like
[Music]
the trail chanson here Christ all fishes
give that three hot kids
yeah that rate of this
I really really really don't know
[Music]
[Music]
hey just relax we just want to get out
of here it's just right nobody's got to
get hurt
hey I really don't think that's the best
idea
[Music]
you [ __ ] to justice father okay
hello it's me Harriet
yes jobless [ __ ] yeah the waivers been
advancing back
disrupt [ __ ]
[Music]
well got him and got that [ __ ] well
oh yeah percent down
take off your glasses just that
[Music]
hey did it [ __ ]
hey Dad Oh a shirt is super clean
lack of ice huh yeah you [ __ ]
murdered him dead
did you did not think I would the
[ __ ] hammer you [ __ ] did it you
are directly responsible and now this
[ __ ] is like water's coming into right
yep
you sure it's too clean to be able to
[ __ ] that's for sure that's why they
make it
that's why I didn't make it it's as
clear as that day yeah okay it's crazy
that [ __ ] just goes like like how long
that's shit's a floater
kiss me Cass Cass Cass Cass please
please I'm begging you kiss place place
all three just kissing the same time all
right let's try it works great
uh-huh
holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] Conrad
right look they see that butters gone
whoa what are the [ __ ] Goliath God
wait there's no one on here did
what the hell is this place is it
abandoned hello Alex Julia are you guys
here no oh I have one second content
you're sorry you're so late to the
goddamn party [ __ ] late to the virus
or sure
oh snap
go be in that chapter right let's see if
that yeah we're gonna shout say yeah
- huh kiss-ass we had this thing where I
was never upset or disappointed you tell
me this crazy [ __ ] about all the
different parallel realities that
potentially exist no matter what they
saying this no matter how bad things
seemed we're always at least a couple
other realities where things were
probably even worse bro are you talking
about
I just want to know what happened to my
brother he was trying to help us take to
get help but he doesn't know anything
about boats are sailing I just hope he's
alive that he's okay how do we should've
never split up yeah
yeah he's Chinese best
I cut her up
oh is that really the [ __ ] end of the
game wait what the [ __ ] was that like no
yes so I saw painting and there was like
another like I'm Tyler death thing
that's it game over you're done for now
at least you could always try again see
if you can't do better next time around
impressive
almost everyone survived almost yea yes
I suppose when the curtain falls you're
either ready for it or you're not
it's all about decisions isn't it
decisions made in a hurry in a panic
made with the heart instead of the head
or vice versa
sometimes those decisions take a long
time to have repercussions but there are
repercussions there are always
repercussions historians this guy's
thing is Pictoris it says I need so many
till we meet again a catering maybe in
little hope maybe somewhere else but
bisa [ __ ] lectures like enough again
yes
okay well anyway I guess thank you for
joining in here not an ending like if
they didn't have College I'm like
so I taught a baby
yeah part I can play that one seems to
[ __ ] darkness thanks for watching you
I hope you all had a good day